I mean I've been talking about this for
15 years it was falling on deaf ears for
so long the whole thing where no those
are contrails when contrails lost
maximum seven seconds in the atmosphere
and you can actually see that you know
they turn on and turn off which ends
that debate right there this has been
going on since the 40s weather
modification you know weaponizing
weather what an awesome way of keeping
the core of the earth cool and keeping
the surface of the Earth cool by
spraying metallic atmospheric
particulates strontium barium into the
Sky cover and have it reflect the sun
back out into space that's the story
it's such an Abomination it's so gnarly
this is an existential threat in my
opinion this is something that you just
you can't walk away from because this
stuff is making its way everywhere it's
getting it's microns size so it's
getting into people's lungs it's getting
into the soil